all right hello there welcome to another
episode in Q&A about history of Science
and Technology I am still not in in my
natural habitat so weird things might
happen but we'll do our
best all right let's see a bunch of
questions that got saved up here one
from Eric how often do separate ideas
emerge like convergent evolution and
merged either complement each other or
make whole ideas that didn't have all
the answers
themselves that's an interesting
question when did things kind of uh uh
sort of surprisingly fit together for
example
um you know I'm kind of thinking there
are examples in the history of
physics where one had kind of a a clue
that things were going on and you know
sometimes like for example an example
would be Brownian motion observed in
1830 or so uh something under a
microscope is kicking pollen grains
around what is it now that wasn't a
terribly famous effect it was kind of a
thing where that was something that was
sort of an obscure effect that was in
the textbooks but nobody really cared
about it then by 1900 people realized oh
there's this quite separate thing of the
development of the idea of molecules and
these things merge together another
example a bit like that where again it's
an obscure effect which wasn't really
known I suppose until uh was the
discovery of the cosmic microwave
background where people had discussed
the idea of kind of big bang hot early
Universe cosmology
and then
1964 is uh there were actual projects to
communicate with communication
satellites and there was kind of this
background um uh radio noise that was
observed but again that wasn't wasn't
like that was a no and phenomenon from a
long time ago let's think there probably
are examples of places where things had
been known for a long time and now it
fit together so to speak
um well you know I suppose one could
argue that things
about the Origin of Species and natural
selection people had known for a long
time there were all these different
Critters on the earth I'm not sure that
that was fully explained by natural
selection I mean that's still an ongoing
issue but it was certainly something
where there was this sort of one thing
was known and then these ideas came in
and there had been ideas about kind of
the uh uh kind of the the the the sort
of the breeding of species and so on
that have predated this kind of notion
of actual Origin of Species I don't
think these are great examples I I kind
of feel like there are examples of this
probably there even examples in my own
life of places where there's sort of
convergent evolution of ideas and where
you need different pieces to come
together to make the whole maybe it's
even something that uh we can see
happening yeah I mean you know it's
constantly the case in our physics
project and in things we're doing yeah
okay I'll give you an example right this
is um yes there is a much better example
okay about the second or of
thermodynamics something I've studied a
lot for more than 50 years actually and
recently put out a book on and so on um
this question of you know how does
Randomness originate how does heat get
generated from systematic mechanical
processes that's the story of
thermodynamics and it was very confusing
to people how how one could go from
something where in principle all these
molecules have sort of determined
motions and so on to something where we
just say the motion seems random that's
the tradition of the second Ro of
themodynamics it originated in the well
in the 1820s more seriously in the
1860s and sort of continued to today and
it was quite mysterious how this all
worked tradition number one tradition
number two the origins of computation
and the ideas of computation and that
was uh originally girdles theorem
touring machines that's 1931 193 six
these are ideas of how sort of processes
take place that correspond to
computations okay it's only in my own
efforts first in the 1980s and now very
recently that one seen that these two
very different traditions of kind of
this computational processes things like
undecidability things like what I call
computational reducibility this is
things from the kind of computation
tradition things from the uh physics and
statistical mechanics tradition of the
second law finally We Now understand how
those merge together and how both we can
we can understand the second law with
these computational ideas and how the
second law helps us to get intuition
about these computational kinds of
processes so I think that's a pretty
good example of where after well sort of
a hundred years with the computation
ideas 150 years for the second lore
ideas these things finally uh finally
have merged together so that that's
perhaps perhaps an
example let's see question from Jamie
here what surprises you most about the
history of Science and Technology what
is that to
learn you
know one is one thing that often
surprises me is many ideas have
precursors there are things where you
say this is new this has never happened
before you realize well actually it did
happen it's one thing that surprises me
another other is when you see that an
idea has a precursor it often had a
precursor without the current context
without the and and sort of the idea was
a was a raw idea that didn't really fit
into other things and people ignored it
at the time and then 50 years 100 years
go by and then my gosh it's it's a thing
another thing that surprises me is the
time scales for absorption of Big Ideas
are very long I mean there are there are
ideas that come in where there's sort of
an enthusiasm for something that comes
in quickly five or 10 years but then the
full absorption of those ideas takes 50
or 100 years and I think the other thing
that you always notice in the history of
science is in retrospect people say oh
yes that idea was accepted immediately
on the ground it was a generation on the
ground it was 20 30 years whatever you
see that with relativity for example
you see that with uh with with sort of
most major ideas I mean these ideas
about computation as a foundation for
thinking about science which which I've
been kind of uh uh developing since the
early 1980s um it you know when I first
developed them people were like oh
that's kind of cool and in some
particular Fields people were like oh
that's interesting we're going to adopt
it but the full sort of yes that's
really the way things work that's
finally kind of it's been 40 years or
more that's finally a thing where people
are likeoh yeah you know that's kind of
obviously the way things work it's kind
of ironic I wrote in the in the preface
to my book A New Kind of Science it came
out in 2002 I I wrote because I knew it
would be the case that you know the
ideas that are in this book at first now
will seem shocking but in time they will
come to seem obvious and 22 years or
something later we're in very much in
the you know we we're we're riding down
the obviousness curve so to speak to
younger people to people who were sort
of first exposed to this in the context
of of these kinds of ideas they do come
to they have come to seem quite obvious
even though at the time they were like
shocking and people couldn't sort of uh
often couldn't get their get their minds
around
them so that's one one kind of thing I
think another thing that is also sort of
interesting about the history of science
and technology is how much individual
contributions matter that is there are
there are times when science develops in
a very Collective way where there's just
a lot of detail to fill in lots of
genomes to work out lots of uh lots of
chemicals to study things like this lots
of detailed things to study but many of
the big advances are very small numbers
of people and uh that's that's something
that in kind of some version of The
History of Science it's just like throw
in more people more things will happen
often not the case often kind of when
you want something really unusual and
unexpected to happen it's only one
person two people whatever who are going
to go out on that Limb and make that new
thing happen if you say let's get the
big Collective to do it the big
Collective is not going to do it the big
Collective is going to be kind of voting
to to do what the sort of to do the
average thing and that's the story of a
lot of large scale science funding Etc
etc those are those are things where uh
the the sort of particularly in
theoretical ideas it's kind of the story
of small numbers of people and and
sometimes even small numbers of people
who where those individuals repeatedly
do things in a particular direction
another thing I suppose I could say is
that at some sense most people who've
made significant contributions in
science uh they have a certain shtick
and that shtick may be one that and
there's sort of a question of does that
shtick resonate with what represents
progress at that particular time in
history and that shtick may be a very
kind of abstracted one where you can use
the same meta methods so to speak across
a bunch of different areas and make
progress but I think all of us uh For
Better or Worse end up developing
certain patterns of thought and there's
a question of sort of applying those
patterns of thought across different
areas for myself I could say that sort
of in lots of different areas where I've
worked it's all sort of a story of well
what's the foundation what are the
underlying Primitives how can you build
up from those underlying Primitives into
a big structure that's what I've tried
to do both in science and in technology
and I've been lucky that that kind of
shtick has worked out really well in a
bunch of different areas and I think
there are even more areas where it can
work well but it's sort of the same
pattern of work um in in and sort of
repeated in different areas and and
that's what you see in most people it's
kind of like there's a particular
approach to doing things and you get to
try that over and over again I me it's
partly a question of once that approach
has worked and you really understand it
it's sort of there's a certain economy
of scale to try the same thing again and
it doesn't tend to be the case that it's
sort of something quite different that
you that you try
next let's see another question here
from
Lola uh history of timekeeping how did
civilizations create the calendar and
clocks what science supports
this you know the story of the of the
calendar is a is a long and complicated
one I I think a lot of what we have so
so sort of the or civilization getting
organized was so far as we know largely
a story of ancient Babylon because that
was the time when cities were first
coming into existence and that was a
time when sort of people had to get
organized it wasn't just oh yeah I know
everybody who's involved and you know
I'll just trade my sheep and my barley
and things like this and it's like we're
all kind of we're all friends and we're
just sort of know what's going on it's
uh it then was there started to be you
know 100,000 people and you had to have
these organized ways of saying you know
there's a price for this and you're
exchanging it with money and how much
barley am I getting oh I can weigh it in
some standard way you know how long is
it going to be rather than oh it's kind
of going to be roughly you know I'll pay
you back in in next season type thing it
started to be the need to be more
precise and I think the um the thing
that uh uh we certainly get from from
the Babylonians I mean they believed
there were at least for a while there
were 360 days in the year that's where
we get the the angles so to speak 360
degrees in a in a full circle the idea
of um uh 24 hours in a day 60 minutes in
an hour um those were I believe
Babylonian um uh constructs I'm not sure
about seconds in a minute um that may
have been Babylonian that may have been
later um at the time the the forms of
timekeeping were there were water clocks
where you just you know you put a bunch
of water in something and you let it
stream out and it takes a few hours and
that's kind of how you how you determine
time and that's good for a day's worth
of time then uh there were astronomical
ways of observing time and those
astronomical ways were uh on much longer
time scales I mean clearly there was a
day was a significant thing there were
also Sund dials where you could kind of
Mark off the hours of the day and of
course those Sund dials changed their
character with seasons and that was a
thing that um
uh that was significant now it may have
been important that sort of early some
early civilization was a bit closer to
the Equator than lots of people live
today that probably had an effect on
sort of the the uh Sund dials don't have
to change as much in in those uh uh
those latitudes um I think uh so those
are sort of two methods of timekeeping
and um when it came when it comes to
sort of longer scale times uh like um
the lunar months where people could
perfectly well see it's a full moon it's
a new moon that was a good way of
measuring sort of longer periods of time
and people were also uh I think very
attuned to what was happening in the
heavens I mean you know clearly if the
only form of light at night is fires you
tend to see much darker night skies you
don't tend to see you tend to be much
more aware of what's happening in in the
uh in the heavens so to speak and I
think people were you know when's the
solstice when's the Equinox those were
things that I think loomed much larger
in people's lives or when's the new moon
when's the when's the full moon so and
so on those loomed much larger in
people's lives back uh in Antiquity and
so on than they do today and so a lot of
kind of observation of kind of what you
know how did those things work what how
long was a lunar month you know how many
lunar months were there in a year how
many days were there in a year these
kinds of things people really paid
attention to that I think the it was
quite early I mean even in in uh
certainly in Babylonian times and
certainly by the time of people like toy
around 1 Century ad there was lots known
about lots of details knowing about
astronomy lots of details known about
different forms of lunar month the
draconic month the the know there
different ways of measuring when does
the moon come back to where it was
before and that is affected by sort of
where the Moon is in its orbit and where
the Earth is in its orbit and so on the
these all these different things were
were were starting to be understood the
Saros series of the 18y year and a bit
kind of way in which the configuration
of the Moon and Sun and Earth came back
to something sort of similar enough that
the eclipses would be the same that was
another kind of thing that was already
known um by the by the uh around 2,000
years
ago so those are all things that were
were understood now there were uh in
terms of sort of the the more detailed
kind of measurement of time um there
were a couple of different dimensions I
mean one was there's a lot of interest
in kind of time on ships because that
was important for navigation but it was
really tough to get you know to keep
time properly on ship and that was sort
of a big challenge that um uh survived
until what the 1700s of you know how do
you get if you want to measure longitude
if you measure latitude pretty easily by
just observing the the position of the
sun and so on but if you want to measure
longitude you need to know the time at
which things happen the time that the
sun rises etc etc etc and for that you
have to have something that reliably
keeps time even though your ship is
pitching up and down so thing that
happened in the 1600s was uh uh
Clockwork and the idea of clocks that
would be um uh uh that that would have
some kind of clockwork mechanism I
suppose what happened before that was
pendulums and people certainly knew
about pendulums and Antiquity I I wonder
whether seconds originated um even in
Antiquity through through a pendulum
swinging back and forth I know Galileo
for example uh was um when he was
interested in measuring time he had you
know he had a pendulum where he could
see how many swings of the pendulum he
also used his own pulse and you know I
think he was a must have been in a good
in good shape cool cucumber or something
uh you know he was like uh my heart rate
is um 60 beats per per per minute you
know one second per heartbeat um I think
uh well G was a small redhaired chap
quite pugnacious so I don't know what
that tells one about about some uh what
knowing that his heart rate he thinks he
claimed at least because he used it to
to measure different kinds of things um
was you know he assumed it was one beat
per second so to speak but I mean the
idea that one could you know one had
pendulum clocks and so on that um
existed and then one had kind of the
notion of clockwork to turn the motion
of the pendulum into the kind of rotary
motion of a of a of clock faces I think
I don't know actually when the sort of
standard clockface was invented I'm
guessing
1600s
um and uh and then kind of later on came
the idea of having Springs to to drive
things and and having this sort of
little tiny uh you know back and forth
uh thing driven by a spring that could
be inside a watch as opposed to the big
kind of Grandfather Clock thing with a
pendulum swinging back and forth um one
of the key things about timekeeping is a
pendulum in a first approximation it
doesn't matter how much the pendulum is
swinging it only matters how long the
pendulum is how long it takes to go from
from uh from one side to the other in
other words you might think as a
pendulum slows down of not swinging
quite as far on from one side to the
other that the time it would take to
swing from one side to the other would
would change but it doesn't in a first
approximation in a first approximation
it's just a formula for the period
That's independent of the uh of how of
the amplitude of the swings that only
depends on the on the length of the
pendulum and the and the amount and the
strength of gravity and things like this
in in the sort of the fancy aversion
involves elliptic functions and things
and it does depend on the amplitude but
for small oscillations the pendulum is
still accurate even though it might be
sort of uh running down and and and
going less to each side than the other
so in terms of things like the calendar
the people uh in different times people
sort of wanted to reform the calendar um
because things had gone wrong with the
calendar it's worth saying that back in
Antiquity uh most dates were so-called
regnal dates they were like in the reign
of King so and so in the reign of
Emperor so and so the first year of that
Emperor's reign and so on the notion of
a sort of an absolute time scale for for
dates is a more recent idea and but then
the question was what about the months
of the year Well famously juliia Caesar
um added I guess added August um
although July is the kind of the Julius
month but August is the Augustus um
month so to speak and uh he did that
because things had sort of gotten out of
whack with the previous months that have
been put put in there and then and then
things ran and at that time leap years
were added and at that times that have
all was running just fine by the
1500s things hadn't gone quite right
because I think in the 1500s what had
happened is because the length of a year
is
365. 2481 days I think um rather than
365.25 days which is what you would get
with the standard rule for years where
you just say add a a leap day add a add
a February 29th every four years um that
doesn't quite correctly uh give you the
right number of days in the year
so the uh what you've got to do is
approximate 365248 one by you know you
could say well I'm going to add a
February 29th at that time I'm going to
not have a February 29th every 100 years
let's say I'm going to have uh uh you
I'm going to I'm going to gradually
adjust you know I'm going to have this
state added and this state subtracted um
every so often and um in 15 what was it
1582 if I'm remembering correctly maybe
I have that date wrong uh Pope Gregory
uh sort of noticed that things had
gotten very out of whack with the
calendar I think one of the one of the
things was that Christmas you know
December 2 fifth give or take had sort
of swung into uh the summer by that time
in other words the the the days of the
year weren't aligned with properly with
the um uh with the seasons so he got
together a group of astronomers and so
on and said we're going to reform the
calendar that led from the Julian
calendar which is what had been used the
Julia Caesar calendar had been used in
kind of the West and and then that led
to the Gregorian calendar the Gregorian
calendar came in very gradually I mean
there were places that were adding the
Gregorian calendar even in the early
20th century um but and it's very
confusing because there are dates like
Newton's date of birth which was
Christmas day in 1642 give or take but
that was in the old style calendar but
by the time Newton was out and about and
particularly by the time he died in
1727 the uh the calendar had been
changed in England from the Julian
calendar to to the gregori calendar and
so his date of birth is a different date
for if you have this particular day that
day is labeled differently in the
original Julian calendar which was in
forced when when Newton was born and the
Gregorian calendar which was enforced by
the time Newton was an adult so it's a
confusing thing but anyway the Gregorian
calendar is what we've used to today um
although there are gradual things that
have to be updated there are leap
seconds that come in um because the in
fact the length of the year that is the
time it takes the Earth to go around the
Sun relative to the length of the day
the time it takes the Earth to to have
one rotation that's continually changing
those relative lengths are continually
changing in fact uh every few years one
has to add or subtract a leap second
because the Earth is roughly slowing
down in its rotation but how much it
slows down depends on what earthquakes
happen it might depend on climate issues
all kinds of things like this I think
there hasn't been a leap second added
for maybe a decade or two but in terms
of of that's sort of how one defines
time there are there are well there are
all kinds of other issues in the
definition of time I mean one thing to
say is is up
until up until the early
1800s different places could sort of
have their own time zone could have
their own time and mostly that was
determined by the Sun and there was the
notion of So-Cal local mean time which
was that's what we we call it today
which was kind of the the the Sundial
time of a particular place but as soon
as people started being able to
communicate across large distances with
telegraphs there were trains going back
and forth by the by the early 1800s then
it became important to actually have
sort of a uniform way of describing
times and uh you know the US was the
place where time zones because it was a
country big enough and with railroads
going far enough and Telegraph lines
going far enough that it became
important to uh uh to define the notion
of time zones and um there were all
kinds of features of time zones and
there there are when I was growing up in
England I barely knew about time zones
um because you know England is a small
enough country as just one time the only
thing one did know about is the notion
of summertime the notion that one would
have daylight savings time one would
switch the clocks so that you know it
was always said so that the farmers
would be uh uh you know so it was
convenient for the farmers I'm not sure
there would have been different
Arguments for daylight savings time at
different times some of them more
convincing than others the thing that
always used to happen in England which
doesn't happen in the US in the US
although there are different states that
can sort of decide to use daylight
savings time Arizona being a famous one
that that uh uh makes different choices
different times and different parts and
so on but there are different um uh the
um the notion of um uh there is a a
well-defined algorithm in the US or at
least there has been for when daylight
savings time comes into effect in
England when I was growing up it kind of
depended on which political party was in
in power whether there was summertime or
double summertime whatever else I I have
to say I didn't follow quite what the
arguments were for for what kind of time
but but it's probably just as well that
computers weren't set up by that time
where there was kind of a uh computers
without networking would have a hard
time with all of these sort of arbitrary
choices of when there is U summertime
daylight savings time or not um you know
somewhere in all of this this question
of sort of how does time get kept
accurately and you know it was all
Clockwork and pendula and things like
that until until the 19 50s when atomic
clocks well actually there were there
were quartz crystal clocks where you
using the vibration of quartz crystal um
that was probably 1940s maybe 1950s but
then then subsequently the notion of an
atomic clock where you're making use of
the actual detailed frequency of uh uh
Atomic exitation levels and things to
determine time where you're basically
just counting how many how many
oscillations of this uh uh occur and
that gives you the uh the passage of
time and now for example the definition
the official definition of of the second
is based on the uh uh the particular
details of the cesium atom particular uh
uh particular frequency of um the
transitions in a cesium atom and that's
um uh that's kind of gives you this time
that's based purely on on the
characteristics of any old cesium atom
now having said any old cesium atom
there is actually a bit of a detail
because it does matter there
gravitational red shift it's affected by
the presence of gravitational fields
things are it it's a little trickier
than that but that's um that's kind of
the modern way of keeping time that is
independent of of looking at the motion
of the Moon the rotation of the earth
and independent of kind of the mechanics
of a a pendulum swinging swinging back
and
forth
the
uh well let's
see hi is asking the history of daylight
savings time and I I I don't know that
in in detail
um the uh Kelly is asking how would you
keep track of sync up all your devices
before they were all networked together
yeah I mean not all my devices are
network together and and I have to say
there are some that haven't made the
change from uh
uh when the last transition of day like
savings time and and sometimes they get
left for six months before they make the
change and I just have to remember
that's off by an hour you know in modern
times there's the thing called nntp the
network uh uh time protocol and there's
this it's in Colorado I think is the the
big source of nntp associated with
National Institute of Standards and
Technology there based on an atomic
clock is kind of this propagation of of
uh of time signals to all the Internet
devices but of course that's tricky
because it takes time for that signal to
propagate to different devices so
there's a whole elaborate story of kind
of how do you know how do you know when
is now so to speak by the way that's
kind of the story of sort of Relativity
and Einstein and all this kind of thing
and when Einstein invented special
relativity in 1905 one of the big
questions was what can simultaneity how
do you know that these two things
happened at the same time and the only
way you can know so of the relative
times is you send a signal from one
thing to the other and kind of the
concept is the fastest you can send that
signal as a speed of light and that kind
of determines what what definitions of
simultaneity you can have but at the
time people were pretty interested in
definitions of simultaneity in
Switzerland where where Einstein lived
uh there was sort of a a let's be very
precise about our train time and things
like that and there were all kinds of
issues of you know are the clocks at
different train stations along the train
line are they all synchronized right and
they were synchronized by electrical
signals going from one to another and it
was sort of a matter of discussion uh
kind of you know would the electrical
signals go fast enough to synchronize
the clock so that they were genuinely at
the same time of course Einstein
realized that genuinely at the same time
is not really something you can Define
in an absolute way that's something that
you have to Define by actually in
signals from one to the other and hence
relativity and so on so but uh that's a
thing that sort of shows up in in
synchronizing sort of clocks on the
internet today we have the same issue
that people had back in those days
synchronizing uh the uh the train clocks
and so
on
uh lcq says
rather
uh rather
complimentarily uh how do you get to
know so much in such depth about how
many different so many different
historical
topics I don't know I think I have a
decent memory and uh I sort of gradually
pick up more and more facts and uh the
um uh the trick is always to to
understand sort of these broader
narratives because if it was just
individual facts there's no chance that
I would remember them the the the way
that one ends up remembering things is
is by uh kind of fitting them into
broader at least for me is by fitting
them into kind of broader narratives and
then there are some things where it's
like okay that's a thing I'm just going
to remember because it's a it's a useful
thing to know like 1642 is a good year
to remember it's the year Galileo died
Newton was born Pascal invented a
mechanical calculator kind of gives you
a sense of sort of what was happening at
that time um I think uh you so there are
useful sort of anchor points to remember
I think also I've been lucky enough to
to work on a lot of different things and
so any given kind of topic I will often
have done a very deep dive into
something sort of close to that topic
and in doing that deep dive I will have
done my homework well enough to have
leared sort of the the slightly broader
area around that topic and that's that's
how one gets to to know a bunch of
things I I've often done sort of deep
dives into the biographies of various
historic
scientific figures and there's always
that deep dive has many details but that
deep dive there are always ambient
pieces of Science History that you pick
up along the way
there let's
see
uh bab is commenting um blockchains
might be the the evolution of agreed
upon ledgers with one single agreed upon
time that's an interesting point I
haven't seen you know people have tried
to tokenize a zillion things you know
they they tokenize the um uh things like
Network bandwidth you know it's kind of
like I'm going to instead of instead of
just I'm going to get tokens for making
Network bandwidth be used I'm going to
get tokens for storing things and so on
interesting to think about could you get
tokens for helping to synchronize time
uh you know by by propagating the nntp
protocol through devices things like
this so I maybe I have this vague
recollection that somebody was trying to
promote a blockchain on that basis but
this notion of
simultaneity blockchains actually do
simultaneity in a rather boring way
typically because the the notion is you
know in something like in in in typical
blockchains it's a distributed Ledger
and what does that mean well typically
that means there are many copies of the
same Ledger there are many copies of the
kind of recording of what happened and
the the question and sort of the idea is
oh there are 10,000 copies or I don't
know how many there are for Bitcoin
these days maybe let's say 5,000 I'm not
sure how many there are um uh different
copies of that same Ledger that says
this is the sequence of transactions
that happened on the Bitcoin blockchain
and the way it works is that any a new
transaction comes in it will get
propagated through this network of of uh
well miners people who have copies of
the of the blockchain of copies of The
Ledger and then it's a question of does
everybody come to agreement about yes
this was a valid transaction let's add
it to all copies of The Ledger that
takes a surprisingly long time I mean
every block is the transactions are put
together in blocks there's maybe 10
minutes per block on a fairly active
blockchain and then then there's the
question of well do we really get full
agreements and often there's a sort of
24-hour timeout for that um and so this
notion of there is a moment when
everybody kind of agrees I I suppose
there there is a notion of simultaneity
there but it's very slow simultaneity
the much more interesting thing is a
distributed blockchain where you really
have the idea that there is only local
agreement in let's imagine all of those
blockchain ledgers were distributed
around the Earth or the solar system or
whatever else and you've got a thing
where uh you locally agree every second
let's say the things that are local
nearby agree that they that they have
the same transactions listed but they
don't necessarily agree with something
further away just as the question of
what already happened you know did that
star go supernova well you know locally
to the the the folks that are there they
know very well that it went supernova
but do we know and at what time do we
say
that you know do we say it went
supernova at 12 noon on August you know
28th or something um what does that mean
does that mean when did we notice that
it went supernova does that mean do we
have a notion of time where we've given
dates that are sort of somehow
correspond to our dates what what does
it mean what what does that simultaneity
mean and so similarly one can imagine
for a blockchain to have something which
is locally coherent but globally not
coherent and it gradually just like in
physics it gradually kind of comes to
Global agreement and actually I've tried
to work out sort of uh schemes for for
distributed blockchain that work using
physics type methods to have sort of
local uh coherence globally not coherent
that leads you to things like you can if
you want to know sort of your your bank
balance if you want to know it quickly
you can know it approximately if you
want to know it exactly you have to wait
for sort of all the signals to come in
from everywhere but um that's uh
um that's a uh uh kind of a some
thoughts about blockchains and
time let's
see
uh go back to some of these
other
questions kelman asks do you think the
free transform is fundamental to Nature
historically it appears in Quantum field
Theory Quantum Computing signal
processing
Etc well what is a for a
transform
so
uh when when I'm talking to you I'm my
vocal cords are vibrating we're
producing producing all these
sounds the uh that those sounds have
different frequencies combined into to
them so for example you on a piano every
note of the piano at least has a basic
frequency associated with it and each
different note has a different basic
frequency if you play a chord you're
going to get two basic frequencies
combined forier analysis is the story of
given that you know what the uh the the
sort of the the pressure wave from The
Sound looks like as a function of time
decompose that into to sort of the
individual frequencies associated with
particular notes in actuality in a piano
the any given note has a fundamental
frequency but it has a bunch of
harmonics of that frequency and a bunch
of other detailed sort of extra
frequencies and that which give the kind
of the tamber of the note um and and
just like with with a human you know if
I tried to you know whistle a a a
definite frequency I probably wouldn't
hit a sing single frequency um and there
will be this distribution of frequencies
and F analysis is the story of of taking
a signal and decomposing it into these
different frequencies and any signal you
can represent either by this is what
happens as a function of time or this is
what happens at different frequencies
and when you take the sort of pure pure
tones of those different frequencies and
combine them together you'll get the
thing that corresponds to the the the
the signal is a function of time another
example of this is with for example the
tides Tides you know the the water is
going up and down at different times of
day and you can just look at the tide as
a function of time you know in this
Harbor the tide was you know plus six
feet at this time of day and minus three
feet at that time of day and in the
course of a day it does this or that in
the course of a lunar month it does this
or that in the course of different
amounts of time it it goes up and down
different ways the in addition to
looking at the tide as a function of
time you can say well what are the
frequency components in the tides and so
then there are definite um I think
there's an 18-year frequ piece there's a
bunch of different frequencies of of
kind of um uh of things going up and
down in the tides so fur analysis is the
story of what frequencies are there in
the signal and it's it's any given
signal you can represent in the time
domain
as just oh it's doing this it's going
louder softer as a function of time or
in the frequency domain it's mostly at
you know I don't know 300 Hertz versus
it's mostly at 800 Hertz and so on these
are equivalent
representations now so that common that
Duality between representing things in
the time domain and the frequency domain
is important in lots of areas of physics
because for example uh if you have
something like like I was talking about
a pendulum earlier a pendulum of a
certain length has a certain
characteristic frequency so if you want
to know this signal how much effect does
it have on that pendulum it matters what
component of that signal is in that in
is in the range of frequencies which are
the natural frequencies of the pendulum
so there are places where it's useful to
analyze things in terms of frequency and
ones where it's useful to analyze things
in terms of as a function of time the
original invention of Fier analysis by
Joseph Fier that was oh boy it must have
been
1810 is um Fier was a a kind of a a
person who worked with Napoleon um he
was partly an egyptologist who went with
Napoleon on his Egyptian uh efforts and
um but he was also a mathematician he
was particularly interested in the
theory of Heat and the question of sort
of how heat how to analyze
how heat would flow in for example if
you have if you heat one end of a metal
bar how long does it take for the heat
to get to the other end so to speak and
he invented Fier analysis as a way to
talk about the different kinds of the
solutions to the heat equation um that
would determine how that how that sort
of heat propagates down the metal bar
people had known about the idea of of
frequencies discrete frequencies in
music and things the pythagoreans knew
about that um and they knew about sort
of the the ratios you know a an octave
as a factor of two in frequency a
perfect fifth is a is three halves ratio
frequency all those kinds of things that
was known to the pythagoreans in the
fifth century BC and um the uh the thing
that um but sort of the the free a story
was at first how do you represent
something in terms of a discrete set of
frequencies then later on it was how do
you make sort of this this this signal
represented either in the frequency
domain or in the time domain so that was
the thing from the early
1800s um I would say that the the way in
which that entered other areas of of
science um a big place where it entered
is in quantum mechanics because it turns
out that in quantum mechanics uh you can
uh the position and momentum are sort of
like the time domain and the frequency
domain so when you have if you have a a
um uh a particle that is um in in kind
of standard quantum mechanics the
momentum of that particle the particle
has a wave function and the wave
function has all these Wiggles in it and
essentially the frequency of those
Wiggles gives the momentum of the
corresponding particle and so this idea
so momentum is associated with uh
frequency in quantum mechanics and in
Quantum field Theory and so on same
story it's it's always the uh uh
frequency domain is what gives you the
kind of things with definite momenta
that is sort of complementary to the the
uh usually called configuration space
representation where it's the actual
positions of things and so when you work
out sort of calculations about
scattering of particles and things like
that you'll usually be you'll be you'll
be often operating and oh I'm going to
keep track of the momentum of these
particles that's a forier component of
the of the quantum field so to speak so
those are those are places now in Signal
processing the the main place where for
analysis comes in is you've got you know
you you're you're talking you've got a
microphone the you know there are there
are pressure waves in the air that
correspond to that are generated by the
motion of your vocal cords and things
like this or or if you're playing a
musical instrument by the by the by a
string moving or or air being blown in a
tube or something like this that's
generating pressure waves and that press
those pressure waves in the in a a
loudspeaker the loudspeaker cone is
wiggling back and forth and pushing the
air in these pressure waves well now the
question is okay so maybe some of those
pressure waves are for us when we
perceive the sound we're like that's a
high frequency sound that's a low
frequency sound for example I don't know
you might have a a hum from something
like a 60 HZ hum from something and you
might say I don't want to I don't want
to hear sounds that are at 60 htz I only
want to hear sounds that are at um uh
let's say 1500 Hertz where lots of um uh
Speech sounds are or something like this
and and so then how do I do that well I
have to filter out the sounds that are
at low frequencies and leave the sounds
that at higher frequencies
and so then I might have a a high pass
filter which passes only high frequency
sounds and that's again a story of fur
analysis and the whole development of
signal processing which is sort of a
story of how do you make for example an
electric circuit that will uh sort of
get rid of lowf frequency sounds and and
the the big idea there is capacitors the
capacitor is something where you've got
an electrical signal and the capacitor
keeps on just sort of storing charge and
then releasing it and and that's kind of
the way in which you sort of buffer up
the uh the individual kind of uh amounts
of current and things and that's sort of
the way that you smooth things out uh if
you want to just pass the high the um uh
in that case that would be just passing
the low frequencies um but but this
whole idea about how do you design a
filter that will pass only certain
frequencies that ends up being a story F
analysis when you analyze electric
circuits it's often convenient to do
that in the frequency domain um and
that's a f analysis story in digital
signal processing one is not using
capacitors and inductors and things like
that to do things with signals one's
instead using one's instead taking the
signal as a digital signal and one's
doing mathematical operations on it and
that's a whole other story Digital
Signal processing I guess got big when
was it when electron had gotten fast
enough probably
1980s um I think that was when sort of
typical signal processing started to
become digital and use computers rather
than using uh discrete circuit
components
um let's
see
question here coming back to
time
um when did time become an important
variable in
science interesting question I mean the
very notion of a variable is really a a
concept of mathematics and that sort of
development of mathematics didn't really
come into existence um until well until
1600s and so on but actually there's a
different thing to say which is when you
make a plot for example you plot a thing
as a function of time you start talking
about things happening as a function of
time I think there was a uh ormus I
think was his name
um that must have
been 1200 something like that that was a
person who started talking about kind of
the the progression of things with time
as a as a kind of a pre-scientific type
of notion something where there was a
kind of a a a things happening through
time as opposed to sort of and and
things like sort of making a plot of the
position of something as a function of
time that seems totally obvious to us
today I don't think it was obvious in
Antiquity I don't think anybody would
have drawn such a thing I mean people
drew geometrical figures but they were
just like here's the triangle it is what
it is right now the idea that you might
draw sort of the the progression of the
the position of the sun as a function of
time I believe that was something that
didn't come in until maybe as late as
the 1400s actually um and this idea that
you are looking at sort of how systems
behave Through Time certainly that is
present in in what Galileo was talking
about uh when Galileo discovered kind of
the the fact that there's this sort of
parabolic relationship between position
and time as something falls under
Gravity there you absolutely need a
notion of how does it behave as a
function of time the idea that um time
would be sort of a variable I think
that's sort of a Galileo type construct
um sort of gets more sophisticated as
soon as you have calculus with Newton
and so on that really time is the you
have this you know these these you're
looking at well Newton had this idea of
fluxion which were kind of variables
that were showing their change through
time you know X dots and things like
this that were kind of a thing that was
not a thing an X so in a sense I suppose
that's a Newton kind of concept of that
that one would have sort of the the
thing X and then the fluxion of x x dot
which is the time variation of X so I
suppose that's a that's a Newton and
calculus kind of story uh and this
notion that one could have the
instantaneous change of the thing with
time which is again not an obvious
concept you could say okay I've got this
happening today that happening tomorrow
I've got sort of discrete moments in
time but this idea that something could
be continuously changing with time my
guess is that's pretty much a construct
of Newton and I think this idea of kind
of uh variables as a thing that you
could really distinguish the the notion
of variables I think that came in only
with Newton
um I think that the idea that you could
have sort of a disembodied algebraic
kind of variable was something needed by
Newton for his studies and mechanics but
it hadn't really been explicitly
enunciated before that
time let's
see
uh
um other question
here
um question here about uh let's
see
um
question from Matt about why do you
suppose no one tried to continue with
Tesla's Nicola Tesla's incomplete
inventions um I don't know that much
about Tesla uh I think um um I remember
number of years ago visiting uh Tesla's
birthplace in in Croatia and realizing
you couldn't drive a Tesla car there at
least at that time because you couldn't
keep it charged in that part of the
world but but I'm sure that's been
rectified in the years since but um the
I mean Tesla was a person with all kinds
of crazy ideas and occasionally some of
them landed in sensible ways I I'm
not I I don't really know enough about
uh the level of definiteness I mean
somehow
in there are people like for
example at
Marone these kinds of people who took
what were sort of idea inventions and
turned them into deployment and
companies and all this kind of thing
Tesla did much less of that and uh the
and and so it's often hard to tell you
know you have the idea for oh I don't
know there lots of things where the idea
existed a long time before it was
reduced to practice the telephone is a
good example the the idea of
transmitting voice over electrical
cables and things that was an idea that
had existed for many years but you
couldn't quite make it work and there
sort of engineering detail to make it
actually work and sometimes sort of the
core idea I mean we could say today that
oh I don't know uh you know the the Star
Trek Communicator became like the flip
phone so to speak and it kind of but the
Star Trek Communicator didn't invent the
cell phone there had to be lots of
details about how you know signal
handoff worked and this and that and the
other to get to the cell phone so it's
always difficult to go from sort of the
raw idea to the engineering deployment
and I don't know you know I think some
of Tesla's ideas about for example
wirelessly transmitting electricity and
uh which you could say is kind of the
wireless charging of today but I don't
know how you know I don't know whether
the engineering problems that had to be
solved whether it's kind of 90% %
engineering problems that had to be
solved and 10% the idea of transmitting
power uh wirelessly that that was was
the story so and I think I don't know
all of Tesla's inventions by any means
but you know I think there were a bunch
of kind of directed energy uh Weaponry
type things and so on and I I you know
again the reduction of that to practice
I think is probably in those cases 99%
of the story so it's kind of like there
are I mean one could as well
let's take a bunch of Science Fiction
and say let's take every invention in
2001 of Space Odyssey and try and make
it real and you know that's sort of a
there's a lot of effort in making it
real so that would be my guess as to why
things didn't quote get swallowed up
because there just wasn't enough there
that it was sort of enough of a
reduction to practice but that may be
quite unfair I mean it may be that there
were there was certainly you know at any
given time there's always a certain
amount of human competitiveness going on
on and and uh you know people saying
I've got my patent you've got your
patent you know how does this work um
and I don't know you know sometimes
sometimes it happens that there are
things that in science and technology
that go the way they go for sort of
purely human somebody was annoyed at
somebody and so they ignored something
um I think that that tends to work out
over the course of time but I'm not sure
how long it
takes
um let's see they wrap up soon here but
um
uh Steve Felipe says as a s engineer I
discover elegant academic programming
languages all the time but they never
seem to gain much traction in Industry
on the other hand we have languages like
JavaScript which was pretty much
developed as a prototype but is now
ubiquitous in web development so I'd be
curious to hear your thoughts on the
history of organic development of
programming languages yeah I mean the
thing to say
is most programming languages at their
core are quite small and you know the
claim that you know JavaScript was
written over a weekend is not wholly
inconceivable because the sort of the
core is quite small to make them
efficient to that that's one thing but
the bigger thing is what's the ecosystem
around them I mean for example hascal
famously originally was a was a very
theoretical language which had no input
output it's like it could sit there and
it could do things internally it could
it's kind of like the disembodied brain
it could be it could think all these
deep thoughts but it could never
communicate them with the outside world
or get anything from the outside world
to say what to do so uh there's there's
you know one thing is is how does the
ecosystem develop of
practicality you know in my own efforts
to build a computational language it's
been a very different story from the
programming languages the programming
languages tend to be yes it's going to
be I can put it together there's a small
number of components I can just sort of
assemble the thing what we've tried to
do with our computational language over
the last 36 years or so is put in all of
these all of these different
capabilities all sort of coherently
organized whether it's dealing with
video or or combinatorial optimization
or knowledge about chemistry or whatever
else to fit all these things together so
there is a sort of a full-scale uniform
computational way of thinking about the
world that's a very different kind of
idea than most programming languages
most programming languages it's like let
wrap some things around the intrinsic
operations of a computer with loops and
variables and things like that and then
that's the core programming language
that's that's pretty easy to construct
at least easy to construct in a first
approximation and then there all these
libraries that start getting added and
different people add different libraries
and there's this this sort of giant uh
well mess typically of of capabilities
that get sort of grafted on that aren't
part of the core language but are just
sort of added uh for practicality of
various kinds most academic languages
never get those things added they never
have they never have the deployment they
don't you know they're getting the thing
to run in all these different
environments and uh you know even these
different kinds of platforms and so on
getting it to be you know in a server
configuration or this configuration that
it's typically those things aren't done
for sort of academic languages because
it's a whole bunch of work and it's a
whole bunch of software Ware engineering
and typically the creation of those
languages is is done for a reason of
sort of the theory of programming
languages not the practicality of oh I'm
going to get a bunch of software
Engineers to make this run in all these
different platforms and server
configurations and how do we deal with
interrupts and what do we do with this
and and what about IO in that situation
and how does it how does it work across
parallel machines or all those kinds of
things those are those are not you know
there is a it's kind of a a tends to be
a let's do this thing to emphasize this
particular theoretical
idea I think the um uh this
usually uh one of the things that
happens with with languages is people if
people use them you can't really change
them because it's kind of like well
there's all this code out there that
works this way and if if you got it
wrong at the beginning you're kind of in
a bad situation because you got to say
oh we're going to break compatibility
python has done that that for example of
breaking compatibility and I I you know
has just horrendous consequences we
fortunately have in the last 36 years
touch wood so to speak never had to make
a major break of compatibility the
things that you know version one
Mathematica program will still run in
version 14 today uh and um that that's
been something I I think we were both
It's a combination of luck and judgment
so to speak um it really helped that
when I was building the first version of
what's now wol from language I had built
a previous system S&P and had made many
of the mistakes in that system so by the
time I was building what's now W
language didn't make those mistakes so
we were able to just take what we did 36
years ago and we've been able to kind of
keep compatibility all that time um but
that's uh that that's something that
happens I would say that um the uh uh
this question of of um some languages
that have been developed for very
pragmatic reasons get propelled by their
use case for example C the C programming
language was the language used to
implement the Unix operating system and
it really got propelled by that by the
fact that people were starting to use
the Unix operating system it was then it
was a nice language but it was then sort
of the natural thing and and people sort
of knew well Unix have been developed in
see that was in the 197 late 1970s and
uh uh you know that was that was a boost
to it I have to say one of the things
that some sometimes disappoints me today
is there's an awful lot of things that
have been implemented in wol from
language like wol Alpha for example like
a lot of systems out there in the world
have been implemented in wolen language
but nobody knows it it's kind of like
you might say we get a big boost by
people knowing gosh you know when I go
into a this kind of retail store and I'm
buying this well it's a a WL language
system that's generating all the data
for that but nobody knows that and and
I'm not sure people care at this point
they just say oh you know the system
works in some way so the sort of the
Boost languages from Yes it got used to
do this it got used to discover this
invent this whatever else isn't so much
there and it tends to be the case that
if there is a if the language sort of
hangs out in in a particular case so for
example JavaScript sort of hanging out
on in web browsers and things uh well
Java famously you know Sun Microsystems
really was pushing you know Java is the
language of the web right when the web
was coming into prominence at the
beginning of the 1990s it kind of uh it
ran up Sun's uh market cap and so on to
say you know son has invented Java Java
is the language of the web that was a
great piece of marketing I'm not sure
that Java really was I mean for a while
it kind of had um it was it was all very
confused because there was Java that was
being run in sort of client side and
there was Java that was being run on
servers and it was it was just um was
all a bit a bit confused for a while I
mean even Java itself had originated in
this thing called jinny I guess which
was a um intended for set toop boxes for
sort of the the the thing to run inside
the um uh inside the thing that went
along with your television um to decode
uh television signals satellite signals
things like the cable signals and so on
and and add additional features but I
think uh you know different languages
have been propelled by their sort of
being part of some system that people
use as uh as kind of a um
um as use for other reasons I mean I
think for example the leure language
very small language was propelled a bit
by its use in games um and and sometimes
again it's a it's a bit of a
self-fulfilling thing that something
gets a language gets used for some
purpose and uh and that brings it sort
of more more visibility than it would
otherwise have and I think uh you know
sometimes languages and and arguably
happen with JavaScript kind of they get
much more usage than they deserve based
on the structure of the language and and
sort of crazy things start happening
like that you're compiling code into
JavaScript um which is kind of a weird
and crazy thing to do um and uh you know
sometimes there are features like
security features and things that some
language might have that uh is sort of
the reason to build a lot of stuff on
top of it but I think um uh this idea
that um uh programming languages end up
sort of developing all these tentacles
of all these libraries and things I
don't think you ever come back from the
tentacles I don't think you know what
we've done in building our computational
language uh sort of my big effort over
the last uh well majority of my Life by
now um the last well it's now 40
something years um of sort of trying to
keep coherence of this of this language
that's sort of a unique thing and it's
something where there aren't at this
point now that we have this giant
coherent thing it becomes possible for
us to add little tentacles and not have
those tentacles as a little tentative
tentacles so to speak of yes we can
integrate some piece of python code or
something and even though and because it
will integrate so well with the big
thing that we already have it you know
we have well- defined ways of
representing images and geoposition and
all this kind of thing and once you're
living in that sort of environment on
that platform the fact that there's a
little tentacle that works in a slightly
weird way is not uh you know it's it
doesn't destroy the coherence of the
whole thing we've got a big enough
coherent uh thing that we can start to
do that although it's certainly our
preference to just grow the coherent
piece but that grows a bit more slowly
you can grow a few tentac t a bit faster
than you can grow the big coherent thing
but I don't think one goes back from the
tentacles I think that's a a level of
kind of heavy lifting that is just not
realistic particularly not in the
context of you know open source
development efforts where kind of the
you know there's complicated motivation
structures about you know what how are
these things getting pulled together or
not and why are people doing things and
so on and and so I think that's you know
we we've could have been the unique
example
of where we're building a very big
computational language more so than than
just a programming language that is that
sort of maintains this consistency and
it's been a lot of work um different
from the sort of organic growth kind of
let's build a library for this let's
build a library for that um kind of kind
of
approach all right maybe one last thing
and then I should
uh
uh okay let's see
um there a question here from hive are
there any pros to using historical
technology or is newer or is better I
don't know I I there people I know who
are using versions of our W from
language or Mathematica that are many
versions back and it's like why are you
doing this you're missing everything
we've developed in the last 15 years oh
well uh you know I want I understand how
the previous works and I know it works I
don't want to do something newer the
fact is that this is the story of
whether one actually maintains
compatibility whether one whether the
new is always better than the old or not
um there are plenty of cases where you
know this is the whole story of uh you
know I want the classic retro type thing
rather than the modern uh version I mean
I suppose you know what what can often
happen is that the new is a bit untested
the old the classic architecture or
something people are used to it it's
kind of been well debugged over the
years it's more convincing than that
piece of of wild modern architecture
where you didn't think oh the roof might
leak or whatever else because it wasn't
sort of a weldy bugged people have been
doing it that way for thousands of years
type type story so I think people
there's uh you know there There Are
Places I'm always it's always
interesting for me because I always like
buying the latest gadgets and so on and
using the L latest stuff um but I also
am quite well aware of the fact that the
latest may be the the flakiest so to
speak I think when it comes to uh I mean
there are places where just the you know
things get developed and the new ideas
are just not very good um there are
things in user interfaces where people
develop them and it's like yeah somebody
might have thought this was a good idea
but it's really not the old version was
actually much better I'll give you an
example of a of a weird one this was in
the early days of workstation computers
this is early
1980s and I was interested in cellular
autometer and in putting these sort of
blocks of black and white squares on a
computer screen and at the beginning it
was really very easy to tell your
computer just stick this this collection
of pixels on the screen in this place
make this picture as operating systems
and uh uh sort of graphic subsystems
became more sophisticated it became more
and more difficult to just say put this
pixel make it black make it white on the
screen and you ended up with these giant
stacks of software to do what should
have been a very simple operation and
and that's something which happened
because well people are interested in
different things more General things
more sophisticated things this
particular use case was kind of left
behind and actually got more complicated
and that's not an uncommon thing people
say we need all these extra features and
some something which was originally this
very simple user interface with three
buttons or something becomes this giant
airplane cockpit kind of uh thing that's
much harder to use so those are places
where you know the the earlier version
is better I mean I think uh you know
it's it's in a sense it's in the skill
of the functional designer whether you
can maintain the the streamlined
efficiency of earlier versions while
still adding those extra features that
people want uh on top of that and that's
something certainly we spend a whole
bunch of time thinking about is how do
we keep if something was nice and simple
before how do we make sure that nice
simple path still exists that nice
simple functionality path exists even
when there are more capabilities that
have been added
separately all right I should probably
wrap up here and uh thanks for joining
me and um look forward to chatting with
you another time so bye for
now